cours de français pour cette classe de
première du lycée victor hugo de
besançon 2 heures pour continuer le
travail entamé il ya plusieurs semaines
les bénévoles d'analystes y sont
présents pour pouvoir vous donner des
conseils pour enrichir veut nouvelles
par rapport aux thématiques que vous
avez choisi écrire une nouvelle
avec au choix quatre thèmes la liberté
d'expression la menace sur
l'universalité des droits la défense des
droits humains et l'esclavagé valentin
et mathis ont créé un personnage dans
une société utopique du futur ou le
passé esclavagiste et cacher les lavages
domestique
au final c'est pas hésiter c'est dans
une information de france
le travail se fait en général par
groupes de trois ou quatre élèves
avec en amont des recherches avant
l'écriture c'est sûr que c'est quand
même des sujets qui nous intéressent qu
on entend parler tous les jours et c'est
je trouve que c'est intéressant ça c'est
grâce aux nouvelles et bat tout le monde
peut en prendre conscience et puis on
peut en parler puis plus simplement
depuis cinq ans muriel tayeb fait
participer une de ses classes à cet
exercice d'écriture sans jamais trop
s'éloigner du programme à la fin de
l'année ses élèves passeront l'épreuve
de français
l'idée c'est qu'ils puissent réfléchir à
des thèmes d'actualité comme ici
l'esclavagé moderne où la liberté
d'expression
et puis les mettre en oeuvre à leur
façon dans des écrits d'invention et
donc là ce que je trouvais intéressant
que la première c'est que c'est un lien
avec l'écriture d'invention qui est une
épreuve du bac de français depuis près
de 60 ans amnesty international défend
les droits de l'homme dans le monde
entier
pétitions pression sur des chefs d'état
pour l'organisation non-gouvernementale
la sensibilisation auprès des plus
jeunes est fondamental se fait donc la
saq et valeo fait ça en touche entre 6 à
800 collégiens lycéens
étudiants chaque année donc c'est une
ouverture pour nous tu as parlé des
droits de l'homme a déclaré étudiants
d'écoles et je pense que c'est un bon
moment pour ce mercredi une grève qui
germera on l'espère un jour on dit tous
les êtres humains
après tu as les rouges qui répondent par
des fibres et égaux en dignité et en
droits la petite graines à germer dans
l'enceinte même du lycée
une vingtaine d'élèves a créé une
section jeunes d'amnesty sous la
houlette de l'ue 6 en début d'année une
exposition a été organisée
d'autres actions de sensibilisation sont
envisagées non juste il ya quelque chose
qui me plaît pas je suis toujours en
train de couvrir la bouche j'ai dit ce
que je pensais donc du coup pour moi
investissent et s et l association qui
me permettait de faire sa part
facilement et demi dit et facilement les
résultats du concours dans les trois
catégories collèges lycées universités
seront connus début février
comme tous les ans un recueil contenant
les meilleures nouvelles sera publié